dès ses débuts comme comédien gilles
pelletier se fait remarquer par la force
et l'intensité de ses interprétations un
simple soldat de marcel dubé les entrées
en direct à la télé de radio canada un
des rôles les plus marquants de sa
carrière
moi ça m'a permis d'aller très loin au
fond du désespoir et de la misère
humaine et dans une pièce qui pour moi
est merveilleuse puis unique dans le
théâtre québécois une pièce épique
en même temps il incarne le capitaine
aubert dans le très populaire téléroman
capot sorcier tout aussi déterminant
pour lui on lui confie à 30 ans le rôle
de l'homme de 70 ans
le bridge on imagine le bruit d'un
capitaine de bateau
c'est pourtant le premier rôle que la
vie lui réserver dès l'âge de 14 ans il
s'engage sur un cargo
j'avais besoin de partir et d'aller moi
je voulais faire le tour du monde et je
partis dans les forces françaises libres
pendant la deuxième guerre mondiale et
joint donc les forces navales a rallié à
la france libre puis rentre à montréal
avec l'idée de reprendre la mer je
devais partir ce bateau puis en
attendant je fais du théâtre parce qu'on
m'a demandé de nismo mis en contact avec
des gens avaient besoin d'un d'un jeune
homme puis sa soeur denise pelletier lui
propose de prendre des cours avec site
aride est ses débuts ne sont pas faciles
ça m'a pris cinq ans avant de dire je
peux marcher sur une feuille dans les
années 50 sa carrière est lancée
il enchaîne les rôles au théâtre joue
même à broadway avec geraldine page et
au cinéma dans alcon fesses du grand
maître du suspense alfred hitchcock mais
une chose me dit une homme monsieur
pelletier suspense is made of dit m
en 1964 il cofonde la nouvelle compagnie
théâtrale qu'il dirige jusqu'en 1982
pour initier des générations d'élèves
aux grands classiques de la dramaturgie
pendant les années 70 il se fait plus
rare à la télévision mais il revient
dans les années 80 notamment dans le
rôle du père xavier galarneau dans
l'héritage de victor lévy beaulieu de
votre pardon attendre canton 2 au nord
il joue aussi dans plusieurs films dont
ceux de denys arcand l'âge des ténèbres
les invasions barbares et jésus de
montréal
l'institution vivent plus longtemps que
les individus glp tiéné plus mais les
grands personnages qu'il aura incarné
resteront gravés à tout jamais dans
notre mémoire collective
je vous dit mme bourbonnais radio canada
montréal